the new normal millions of us working
from home with all the joys and
challenges that go with it but even at
home there's no escaping the cost of
living we're both running computers and
you know printer and all those kind of
things and
um yeah you just you just notice that
it's just more expensive to live and i
think
grocery bills and fuel for the car and
just just all round i think everyone's
feeling that
their weekly and monthly outgoings are
just creeping up should we read the book
together
higher bills and higher prices for
businesses like ruth's which makes
children's books as a small business my
sales this month and last month are down
by 30 percent um and so yeah so 30
of down in sales plus 30 increase in
costs it's just it doesn't make business
sense anymore so
yeah unfortunately it's going to have to
be passed on and i'm i'm really
terrified that it's going to put people
off
what do you get when you extrapolate
that across a whole economy i think we
all know the answer inflation the
consumer price index a measure of how
fast prices have risen over the past
year is supposed to be close to two
percent that's the bank of england's
target but it's now risen to 4.2 percent
not only is that higher than expected
it's the highest level for a decade and
it's only likely to rise higher
why is that because price prices seem to
be pretty much everywhere you look
graham's construction firm is at the
sharp end of it
most the prices have gone up in material
cost some labour costs are now going up
and extremes that we probably never
experienced for a long long time
um you know we've increased size of
steel timber
cementitious materials raw materials
going up 25 50 and in some cases even
more
there's no single reason for the supply
crisis post covered rebound industry
specific issues problems getting workers
trade disputes and so on but the upshot
is scenes like this containers piled up
on an airfield near felix stowe docks
unable to do what they were built to do
and higher prices everywhere one of the
many prices on the rise is that of
second-hand cars up by more than 27 in
the last six months alone why is that
happening it's because there aren't as
many new cars on the market new cars
very reliant on semiconductors computer
chips and there's a global shortage of
computer chips you see the point here
international issues are feeding into
domestic inflation and that's why the
bank of england thinks there's only so
much that it can do
still it is expected to raise interest
rates perhaps as soon as next month it
won't be a big increase but life is
about to get even more expensive
ed conway sky news